this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes of
poor sleep and heat has always been my
nemesis
i've suffered for decades tossing and
turning throwing blankets off putting
them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now i am
falling asleep
in record time faster than ever why
because i'm using a simple device called
the pod pro
cover by eight sleep it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature
it pairs dynamic cooling and heating
with biometric tracking to offer the
most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
aidsleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this so
i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress
and start sleeping as cool as 55 degrees
fahrenheit or as hot as 110 degrees
fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures
on either side which is exactly what
we're doing now for me
and for many people the result eight
sleep users fall asleep up to 32 percent
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys
you can get two hundred and fifty
dollars off of the pod pro cover that's
a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim or use code
tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t
sleep.com tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-m-eight sleep dot
com
slash tim for 200 off your pod pro cover
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
what on earth is element it is a
delicious sugar-free electrolyte drink
mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw covid coming down the pike
and i usually use
one to two per day element is formulated
to help anyone with their electrolyte
needs and perfectly suited to folks
following a keto low carb or paleo
diet or if you drink a ton of water and
you might not have the right balance
that's often when i drink it or if
you're doing any type of endurance
exercise
mountain biking et cetera another
application if you've ever struggled to
feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because
even if you're consciously consuming
electrolytes you're just not getting
enough
and it relates to a bunch of stuff like
a hormone called aldosterone blah blah
when insulin is low but suffice to say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick-ass
no-sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former research biochemist and
two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a
low-carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units fbi
sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on
and on you can try it risk free if you
don't like it element will give you your
money back no questions asked they have
extremely low
return rates element came up with a very
special offer for you my dear listeners
for a limited time you can claim a free
element sample pack
you only cover the cost of shipping for
u.s customers this means you can receive
an eight-count sample pack for just five
dollars
simply go to drink element.com tim
that's drink lmnt.com
tim to claim your free 8 count sample
pack one more time that's drink
l lmnt dot com slash tim for this
exclusive offer
drinkelement.com tim check it out
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i ask you a personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i'm very excited for this episode
and i'm going to skip my usual preamble
to jump straight to the guest my guest
today is
anne lamott you can find her on twitter
and instagram at
anne lamott that's a-n-n-e-l-a-m-o-t-t
and uses honesty empathy and humor to
write about our world
in her beloved and best-selling books
like operating instructions an account
of her son's first year
bird by bird her classic book on writing
and i will have a fair amount to say
about that
and help thanks wow a celebration of
prayer
lamont delves into what makes us human
she explores the wide experience of life
that unites us
birth and death parenthood and family
faith and doubt
love and loss forgiveness and hope in
each of her 19 books which have sold
millions of copies worldwide
le mans brings her distinctive mix of
bracing candor clarifying insight and
refreshing humor to convert serious
subjects like addiction motherhood loss
and faith
into human truths we can all share she
is the author of several essay
collections on faith including traveling
mercies
grace parenthetically eventually and
plan b
as well as several novels including
imperfect birds blue shoe
and rosie lamotte has been honored with
a guggenheim fellowship and has taught
at uc davis and writing conferences
around the country
she is an inductee of the california
hall of fame and the subject of academy
award-winning filmmaker freda mock's
documentary bird by bird with annie from
1999 her most recent book
is dusk night dawn subtitle on revival
and courage
annie welcome to the show it's so
exciting that you are here and we're
finally connecting
thank you tim i'm so honored and i just
want to say i think
my son takes me a lot more seriously
because you were interested in having me
on
oh well wait until he hears the back
story and uh
and i was very happy to meet sam just
a few minutes ago before we started
recording
and the back story is as follows when i
was working on
my first book four hour work week the
blessing and curse
that that title has always been but at
the time pre-publication working on this
book
and i made it about halfway or
two-thirds of the way
in and realized holy [ __ ] this structure
the entire
lattice work that i thought i had
created so perfectly is not going to
work
at all and then i proceeded to promptly
have
in retrospect it was probably a complete
nervous breakdown began self-medicating
with copious amounts of caffeine and a
little bit of alcohol at night
and went into this spiral of self-doubt
and loathing and
was absolutely convinced i was going to
have to throw in the towel
return the advance lick my wounds and
move on and someone gifted me bird by
bird and this cannot be the only time
you've heard this but it
proved to be an invaluable life raft
or maybe some type of resuscitation
device maybe both
and it is i would say no short measure
one of the most important components
that allowed me to
finish that book furthermore the years
following
led me to meet many people including
friends like ramit seti and when he was
writing his book
he also crossed this rubicon and
landed in the territory of self-loathing
and was going to do the same thing he
was going to quit he just thought there
was no way out he was trapped in a maze
gave him bird by bird he was able to
finish and his book became a new york
times bestseller
and you must hear this all the time
and i'm going to ask a question that no
doubt you've been asked before but i
have to ask
what do you think it is about bird by
bird
that affected so many people so deeply
and certainly that's true of
many of your other works but in this
particular case
what do you think it is that has that
type of effect on people
i think it's because i didn't try to
con people into thinking that if they
just got a book finished
that my agent would want to take a look
at it by the end of the week and that it
would almost certainly be published and
that then they would
all the swiss cheese holes inside of
them would be healed and they'd be well
and they'd get that fda stamp of
approval and be validated
and then their parents would start to
respect them i said none of that's going
to happen
all of that is an inside job but i'll
tell you a funny story when
sam's little boy who's 12 now was five i
was teaching his
kindergarten class a writing workshop
and instead of saying shitty first
drafts i said really poopy first drafts
but after and the kids loved me and
after i was done
my little grandchild came up to me and
he leaned in and he sounded like
tony soprano he said oh nana that was
terrible
and i said what and he said you told
people you would teach him how to write
a book but you only taught us how to
write one page
and that's really what i can help you do
is one chapter is on shitty first drafts
i don't try to teach kids or grown-ups
how to write really really well i just
teach them
to stop not writing i teach them to keep
their butt in the chair and to write
badly
and that all first drafts of any book
you've ever read by the
authors you esteem most began as
unreadable first drafts
and i teach people to take it really
small you know bird by
bird is it okay if i tell the story
please please i i i would love for you
to tell the story just so people know
the genesis
well my older brother i was like a
superstar achiever in school and my
older brother hated school and he was
kind of a rebel
and in california in the 50s and early
60s
in fourth grade you wrote two term
papers one was the sacramento paper
that's our state capital and the other
was on birds
and you had to write it all year all
semester a paper on birds and my brother
hadn't started it was due on a monday
and on a saturday
he admitted to my dad that he hadn't
started my brother was a tough guy and
he was in tears and my dad sat down with
him and put his arm around him and he
said just take it bird by bird buddy
you know first you read about chickadees
and then you write a paragraph
in your own words about chickadees and
then you draw a picture
and then you take pelicans and you study
up on pelicans and then you write a
paragraph or a
passage on pelicans i never ever forgot
that
and then years later probably 20 years
ago so
in my 40s i heard el doctoro say
that riding was like driving at night
with the headlights on you could only
see a little ways in front of you
but you could make the whole journey
that way and i think that is the most
profound advice i can offer anyone on
any topic
that you you you can only see a little
ways in front of you and and you can
make the whole journey that way
and another another thing that i think
helped people when they read bird by
bird was
the chapter on perfectionism and how
perfectionism is the voice of the
oppressor it's the voice of the enemy
and if you listen to it keeps you crazy
for your entire life because
because we all fall short you know
you've written books and you think
you're creating this golden and crystal
palace that people can walk inside of
and see all of truth and beauty
and reality and you kind of end up your
books and my books
all all of them are kind of shanty towns
you know and like
indeed during the peace marches where
people
set up tents and thought it made sense
to bring their dogs you know during the
rainstorm
and that's a miracle to written a
shantytown and so
i think these ideas of not knowing what
you're doing
and of letting yourself do it really
badly
and to try to help grind down that
critical voice i'll just mention my
husband's
work here he he's uh neil allen he wrote
shapes of truth
and the work he does with people and
these shapes of truth is taming the
inner critic
and what his position is you're never
going to get rid of it you know we don't
get over
very much here what he does with people
is he has him bring
forth the inner critic and actually just
put it on the table in front of him
and he he thanks them for keeping them
him alive
when he was six and seven because it
kept him small
and controllable so he didn't run out
into the street he didn't swim out past
his ability to stay afloat
but that at the age of 60 or whatever we
probably don't need it anymore
and so he has his clients give the inner
critic
a great new job which might be ethical
consultant for the project so that the
inner critic can go off to the library
where there's an incredibly comfortable
chair and a good reading light and 2
000 books and he will sit there and read
which he loves to do
and when we need an ethical consultation
we'll come get him
but we don't need that constant
is it allow okay to say the f word on oh
yeah oh yes please
oh in bird by bird there's a whole
chapter on k [ __ ] radio
kfkd and without a lot of help and a lot
of transformation and healing
k [ __ ] radio's on 24 7. it's telling
you how far short you're falling it's
telling you
how great you started out and what a
disappointment you've turned out to be
it's telling you that what you're in the
middle of
is beating a dead on and on and on and
so the
shapes of truthwork and the inner critic
work
and bird by bird is 90 percent
about turning down k [ __ ] radio anyway
out of the left-hand speaker is all this
stuff
about that you you can't do it perfectly
and that
why bother and that this has been blah
blah but out of the right-hand speakers
it's like the voice of the people who
love you most the voice of like for me
sam or my husband or my two best
girlfriends and they're saying
i love your stories i love how you write
i can't wait to read more so but you can
turn down the left-hand speaker and
it'll always be there to some degree
there are many different directions i
could go and
thank you for that context i am going to
sit down and re-read
bird by bird in fact which i've read at
least
i would say a dozen times but i'd always
written
non-fiction and i'm beginning to
experiment with fiction which is
a whole different sport it would seem
freeing in many ways i can help you can
help me because
i i if you want someone to help you i
will help you
because that's all the same stuff you
sit down you keep your butt in the chair
you take one passage one memory one
vision one bit of dialogue one character
and you do it badly
yeah so
if we look back to your childhood
my understanding is you had a role model
for this
this button chair time could you tell us
a bit about
your childhood yeah well the
model was my father who was a writer
kenneth lamott and he had a lot of books
published in a lot of
magazine articles and i heard him down
at his desk at that old olympia at 5
30 every morning rain or shine or
hangover he just did it
and that was what he taught me was that
you don't wait for inspiration
it's an illusion and in fact i gave a
talk once on inspiration
on how i don't believe in it and how
what gets me going
is debt mental illness
desire for revenge but my dad just did
it
and that's what i learned and that's
what i passed on to my son
and my house was very very tense my
parents didn't love each other my father
drank a lot
my mother was very very overweight and a
black belt codependent from liverpool
and i was the middle child i have an
older brother and a younger brother
and it was up to me to help make sure
dad kept coming home because he didn't
like mom but he
loved me i had a rebellious older
brother and an infant baby brother and i
needed to
try to help raise the baby brother i
mean my parents really would have been
better off raising
orchids or teacup poodles or something
and so
what i did at the age of five was to try
to raise the baby and to try to keep my
brother
from imploding and it was exhausting and
i got migraines
at five years old and no one it was 50s
no one quite noticed
that children had mental health
diagnoses
and stress there was really life or
death but i'll tell you
my family worked better when i had a
migraine because families do well if
there's one sick person that's not them
so when i had to be in the total
darkness with cold compresses the family
thrived
you know but i learned a couple of rules
and i know you've written about stuff
like this but i learned
some survival tools and one was to think
that i was defective and that i was the
reason that the family wasn't doing well
because if i was the problem that meant
i had some measure of control
right i could do better and i couldn't
do better i was an a student i was a
tennis star
but if i i believed i could do better
and i could need
less and if i did better and needed less
then it seemed to make mom and dad
better and it was completely reaganomic
trickle down like if
dad was okay and we helped dad pump up
then mom would be able to
nurture the three of us so born to die
people pleaser
i got all of my self-esteem from outside
from good grades from being the star of
the classroom and from being a great
conversationalist that my parents
like to have around and that my parents
friends like to chat with
and i was not only defective and this is
where it gets
dicey but i was in charge of everybody's
happiness you know i was in charge of
of helping mom not feel so put down by
dad i was in charge of
making dad come home because i was so
adorable and i rubbed his feet
i'm a lot older than you but when i was
coming up in the 50s the men
they all were socks with garters these
little sock garters
and i was like a little geisha girl with
curly kinky hair
and i'd sit and i'd take off his little
garter on the couch and i'd take off his
sock and i'd rub his feet
and i thought he would come home for
that and he drank a lot
so what i got good at was pleasing
people
being a stratospheric achiever but not
quite so
bright that it ruined my older brother's
life and it made him feel like a loser
and i know how to raise babies
and i know how to get by on the
leftovers on whatever was left over
after i gave everybody the very very
best parts of me
so all of my books including bird by
bird and operating instructions
everything
has to do with that coming into
radical self-care and becoming my own
priority
this is kind of funny my mom who is a
black belt as i told you codependent
always took the broken fried egg
my entire life i can swear
on a stack of bibles my mother never
once said here's somebody
else take the goddamn broken egg yolk
can
you take the you know my mother ate the
broken egg yolk and that's what i was
raised to believe women did
and i had to have enough therapy enough
recovery i've been clean and sober 35
years now
and enough in the women's movement and
a lot of outside help so that i could be
my own priority
and if there was a broken egg yolk maybe
it wasn't my turn again maybe sam should
have the broken egg yolk
sam loves a perfect fried egg you know
what tough [ __ ]
i know that sounds like a loving
christian thing to say but
it had to do with becoming my own
priority
so that was the childhood i had i was
very afraid i had
migraines i was too smart i was very
good at math
girls weren't supposed to be i skipped a
grade i made the boys feel bad because i
was better at math than they were
i was small and i looked funny i had
this crazy
pure white blonde kinky hair and these
huge green eyes i weighed
about 20 pounds till eighth grade and
you know
all i knew to do was to do better and to
try to do it perfectly and that's why i
think the chapter in bird by bird is
something
that people so relate to because like in
my family
all of us in the american way in fact
but in my family
the theme was forward thrust that no
matter what was going on you keep going
you keep going forward you thrust
forward and
so that the abyss doesn't open up at
your feet you know and
and if the abyss threatens to you you
get ikea and you buy a cute throw rug
you know you trick out people and they
call the abyssi abyss because it's
pretty invisible
it's a nightmare so you try not to land
in it what my family did was drink and
overeat and diet
my dad had a million affairs and it
turned out and you've written about this
that the abyss or in the christian you
know theology of saint john the divine
it's the dark knight of the soul
is where transformation most often
happens and that if you can just bear
being somewhere that you've never been
before
where you don't really have any kind of
owner's manual or a clue
of how to proceed then you're really
teachable
you know and from that place something
magical might just grow
i want to ask you a few questions that
are going to be interrelated
so i'll tell you what they are and then
we'll come to the first one so
you asked me a question before we began
recording you asked me several questions
you asked me how i was doing you also
asked me if i was
spiritually fit or feeling spiritually
fit i don't remember the exact
wording but i'd like to hear to you what
that means
and then after that what it means to you
current day
after that i'd love for you to tell us
the story
or any story of a dark night of the soul
experience that you've had
that helped to catalyze this radical
self-care but let's start
in the present tense spiritually fit
what does that mean to you
well spiritually fit means i'm in my
body
paradoxically it doesn't mean i'm in
some ether world of
you know divine enlightenment and it
means i heard a
preacher years ago say the 23rd psalm
which is the lord is my shepherd i shall
not want
but she said the lord is my shepherd i
shall not
trip and i just love that because when
i'm spiritually not fit i'm
just tripping you know i'm making up
stories
i'm in fear i'm in anxiety i have a i
have a tremendous anxiety disorder for
which i'm successfully
treated most of the time but i'm just
tripping on something somebody said that
it's stuck in my craw
on something i'm afraid of of something
a lot of fear in recovery there's some
great acronyms for fear
because people like my cokehead friends
i mean i'm my own cokehead friend
but they would say that the false
evidence appearing real
which usually means that you're at the
window peering through the drapes
thinking that there are there's a swat
team
on your lawn at four in the morning you
know and that the only the best idea you
have is another cool
refreshing beer but some of the ones i
love is one is the frantic effort to
appear recovered
that's my main thing is that when i need
to look good
when i need to appear to be doing well
is when i'm at my most spiritually
lost and another one i love is
future events already ruined and so i'm
just tripping out
like i was tripping up this morning
about what if i screwed up with tim
you know and and you're so illustrious
and your
listenership i think is younger and why
would they want this old
lady with dreadlocks as sunday school
teacher
where do our zen diagrams meet and i was
tripping and then i remembered
you know future events already ruined
that's not true that's just
k [ __ ] radio and another one i love is
fear expressed allows
relief and so i told hill and he said
you know you
you are so wonderful at this just
breathe and go for a walk first and do
what you do and you'll be sitting there
with sam
and tim is great and you're gonna love
it it's gonna go by so quickly
but so fear express allows relief so
spiritually fit for me is that i'm not
tripping
and that i'm breathing when i was a
child i didn't breathe
you know i held my breath because for
all the reasons i told you
and i remember i used to pass out on the
boardwalk in town
at three years old and my dad would
nudge me
and say annie annie and i blink awake
but if you breathe
you may end up in your body and it may
be that in your body
terrible things happen to you and if
you're a girl
addict an alcoholic like i am you know
until
1986 you let terrible things happen in
your body you encourage
terrible things if you let people do
anything at all that they want
they seem to like you better briefly you
know and so
breathing will bring you into your body
so for that reason
you may resist it but for me to do what
i call the sacrament of ploppage
and to sit down and for one minute
to breathe into my heart cave
and do the do the sighing i get my sense
of humor back
you know and laughter even at my own
quirky fearful darling self laughter
i've
written in a number of places is
carbonated holiness
so if i'm breathing and i've gotten my
sense of
humor back i'm in something spiritual
i'm something that has to do with my
human spirit
and the divine i mean i believe and and
i've i've heard
that we have dual citizenship you know
we're we're children of the divine
we're children of sons and daughters of
god and we also have these
kind of screwed up biographical
details we've got genetic details that
we would have maybe not
preferred we have predispositions to
alcoholism and mental illness or to
weight gain in our thighs or whatever
but i have to remember that i can
toggle back between dual citizenship
between being a child of god or of the
great universal spirit and annie lamont
67 sunday school teacher and left-wing
activist
mother and grandmother and you know i
got married at 65. i got married three
days after i got medicare
and those are my true biographical
details and i also
am a person of spirit so that's what
spiritually fit
means for me is that i remember that i'm
not
this terrible pinball machine in my mind
cranking out
new ideas about how i can do life more
perfectly so that everybody
will think more highly of me
annie i want to tell you i am
enjoying this tremendously so you are
you are exceeding every expectation
so uh i'm very very happy
that you're here and thank you for
making the time to be here you mentioned
this radical self-care
and having written a lot about radical
self-care and what a contrast that is to
your
early experiences or earlier experiences
in life was there
or is there a particular catalyzing
event
that brought radical self-care into
focus
as a imperative for you well two things
spring to mind i mean i could write a
whole book on the darknet of the soul
and every book i've written
is about it to some degree but it's my
favorite topic
and i just had a million dark nights of
the soul
while i was drinking and using and
usually the solution then was to have
eight or nine social vodkas and maybe a
little anal nitrate just to socialize
but then in 1986 the fourth of july
weekend
i had a three day blackout which is so
unfair i'm not kidding because usually
you have a blackout and you know it's
like a wet
chalkboard eraser has come by and
there's nothing left on the chalkboard
of what you did that evening
and it's very scary but usually they
don't happen all that often
i had three in a row july 4th july 5th
and july 6
and i woke up in terror
the morning of july 7th and i had run
out of any more good ideas
all i could think of was how i could
figure out a way
to learn to drink more successfully
and i knew that i wasn't going to be
able to break that code and i was
already a believer i mean i've pretty
much been a believer my whole life
i already had a church by then i um i
was just done
i'd reached the end of my rope that's
what the dark knight is you've run out
of any more good ideas
and in that space of total emptiness
and lostness i was lost
and something found me and i have to
think of it as grace
i understand grace to be spiritual
wd-40.
that it spritzes you maybe a really
quick spritz or maybe it
maybe you get that the little thin red
straw inserted into you and you get a
sustained
spritz of it but it was like water wings
i
suddenly understood that i wasn't gonna
sink completely
but that i needed a lot of help and that
was a huge
breakthrough for me well the help i got
first
i got a couple of sober women
who said i have what you have and i
found a way out
one day at a time not drinking just for
the day and
if your ass falls off we can help
pick it up and carry it to where we are
and we'll sit together and we'll share
our truth and you won't have to drink
for the rest of the day
and we'll help you get through the day
just without a butt
the amazing thing about grace is that it
meets you exactly where
you are and then it doesn't leave you
where it found you
you know it sort of tricks you into
getting into its wheelbarrow
and then it moves you to some place
where maybe there's just a shaft of
light
or maybe there's cool water and the cool
water i found
was other sober people but that was the
darkest night i can remember
and then here's here's a recent example
my son and his son live here
in a barn on the property and his son
lives with him half time and with
the child's mother half time and i was
in
major major people pleasing and i was
dancing i was just dancing as fast as i
could
to make sure everybody's needs were met
and i was taking the leftovers and the
broken egg yolks
and i was exhausted i was in existential
exhaustion and it had been going on for
a while
and i finally i know i shared it with my
older brother who'd stopped by who's a
fundamentalist christian and he
he sort of basically done the equivalent
of handing me some nice christian bumper
sticker
about how god never gives you more than
you can handle which i think is a total
crock
and i think what you got to do with god
is to convince him that you really can't
bear all that much
like when you deal with a trainer at the
gym you don't want them to know how much
you can lift because they'll make you
lift it and that what you have to do
is instead to just pretend you can't
pause and hint at liability
from another gym you went to where they
made you live too much
when my brother handed me this stupid
word
bumper sticker i lost it and i said to
him
like one of the coneheads i said i have
to go right this minute now and go for
a ride i have an errand to do and my
older brother looked at me like
what and i got in my car and i drove out
to the woods and screaming and shouting
and pounding the steering wheel and it's
saying i
hate you sam i hate you to his mother
i hate you john who's my older brother i
hate you mom and dad you taught me that
i'm a piece of [ __ ]
unless i'm getting a's and unless the
entire world and i
i hated everybody and i it was half hour
i turned around half hour same record
and then finally i pulled over to
sidereel and i i called my
my spiritual mentor whose name is
horrible bonnie and that's what i call
her anyway
and i said i hate i cannot stand it
all i do is be there for everybody else
and i get
nothing i know and i went on and on and
she listened
which is the miracle that somebody
listens and they don't try to save or
rescue or fix you
or horse you into submission to what
they think would be a good path for you
and she said annie this is what we paid
for
this is where i hoped you would get
someday and i wasn't in cute adorable
crying i was in
red-faced swollen nose carl
mauldin snotty crying i said no but i
don't have any
i don't have i've tried everything blah
blah blah blah
she let me cry and she said you are
everybody else is your priority
that your son and your grandson and your
mom your relatives and that your best
friends
and that your people at church and the
blah blah that everybody else
is taken care of and you get leftovers
and it was the
darkest snottiest wettest dark night of
the soul
and it wasn't like god reached down with
this magic or his or her magic wand and
tapped me
it really hurt i was really angry
about what i've put up with and i was
sad
and angry and freaked out and we just
stayed on the phone and then all of a
sudden i could breathe again
and i drove back to my house and i
became my own priority and my older
brother was there and he goes
hi you seemed kind of i said oh no i
didn't you know oh no i'm fine
and frantic effort to appear but from
that point on
i can tell you what date that was
because three months later i met the man
who became my husband i did
three months of this radical self-love
of being my own priority of letting
everybody else take the leftovers
of putting myself first of structuring
my days around what would make me
happiest what i needed to do and what i
hoped to do and what i
loved to do and then i would find time
for everybody else
and three months to the day later i met
neil for our first coffee date and that
was five years ago we haven't been apart
for a day since so that was the most
recent dark night of the soul
my son who's right here had a very long
stretch of
mass and alcohol where i thought he
would die that was the most terrifying
thing to think i could lose him
because he's my outside heart you know i
think children are our outside heart
and i couldn't save him i couldn't fix
him i couldn't rescue him
i couldn't really help him but the
darkness of our soul
was that he had a two-year-old child he
had a baby at 19 and
the mom and my grandchild were living it
with me
and sam was around but he had a house in
the tenderloin
he had an apartment and he showed up
wasted
and i had reached my bottom that's what
the dark knight is you've run out of any
more good ideas
and so what i did was i took a sharpened
pencil
and i held it to his throat i mean this
does not
jibe with my spiritual books my my
persona and my being
school teacher and i said you're as bad
as any
junkie i know and you cannot be back on
this property with your baby
if you so much as have a hit of
marijuana and we just looked at each
other and he looked at me
like with such hatred and for your child
to hate you is about as bad as it ever
gets
and then i got some sort of holy spirit
nudge or
something you know the great universal
spirit and i said do you want to ride
back to the city
and to the tenderloin i don't know if
you know what the tenderloin is
oh i do i lived in san francisco a long
time but a lot of people don't so could
you describe it please
not lovely it's where all it's where all
the the crackheads and heroin out it's a
really
deprived depleted addicted
prostitute pimp terrible terrible
place and anyway so i drove him back to
his house and he got out of the
car and he hated me and i walked over to
him
and i reached for him i took a chance
you know they say
courage is fear that has said its
prayers we hadn't said a word in the car
it's an hour drive
and i i just kept praying in silence in
the car and we stood together and i
reached for him
and he reached for me and i i said i'll
see you and he said i'll see you
and then he called me three weeks later
and he said
i've got a week clean and sober and the
guys who could actually be there for him
which was not his
incredibly crazy mother who had had it
these guys in san francisco who were
clean and sober had fished him out of
the trough you know
and one day at a time had helped him get
clean and sober and he had sent a drink
or a drug for 10 years now
so those three things that i've
described are what are the darkest
nights
of the soul that i've been to but to
sing with sam and with my
child in general is that i had thought
up until then that i had some real
i have a disease of good ideas usually
for other people
and i believe that my ideas will really
help them have better lives and at least
make me less
uncomfortable when i'm around them and i
learned that
my help was not helpful to sam and that
help
is the sunny side of control and i was
trying to control him and that was
making him worse
and i still you know i'm 67 he's going
to be 32 this year
i still he's on his hero's journey with
his podcasts
hello humans that you've listened to and
he's doing a beautiful job
and i would still like to get on his
hero's journey just maybe 10 feet behind
him with
juice box and sunscreen maybe and just
be there in case he needs me but when i
do that
it's injuring him it's not helping him
certainly not helping me
but what i have to do is is the
awareness that i'm doing it again and
grip myself gently by the wrist and say
annie
stop get back onto your own emotional
acre
he's doing great he is a miracle
that's what has come from the dark
knights are the the greatest truths i
know
that my my help is not helpful that when
i'm in the darkest
most scared place on earth if i can not
try to do the forward thrust
and try to redecorate the abyss that i'm
going to get
blessing and light and i'm going to get
fresh air
so and i'm get you know my life is if i
can tough it out or let somebody into it
with me
and breathe and do left foot right foot
left foot breathe that my world is going
to become more spacious
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs it's summer of 2021
and with all the rapid changes we've
seen since last year small business
owners are busier than ever
time spent searching for and
interviewing the wrong candidates for
job opening
could be time better spent growing a
business growing your business
that's why linkedin jobs has made it
even easier and faster to reach
candidates worth
interviewing create a job post for free
in minutes on linkedin jobs
to reach your network and well beyond to
the world's largest professional network
of more than 750 million people
that's a lot of people focus on
candidates with the skills and
experience
you need use screening questions to get
your role in front of only the most
qualified people then use the simple
tools on linkedin jobs
to quickly filter and prioritize who
you'd like to interview
and then hire linkedin jobs helps you
find the candidates worth interviewing
faster did you know that every week
nearly 40 million
job seekers visit linkedin post your job
for free at linkedin.com
tim that's linkedin.com tim to post your
job
for free terms and conditions apply
so i want to i want to underscore a few
things
and follow up on a few things the first
that i want to note is
sam's podcast as you mentioned i
recently listened to his episode
on the how to human podcast and people
can find many interviews online at
hellohumans.co that's dot co hello
humans dot co and we'll link to that in
the show notes
his episode with paul williams the famed
singer-songwriter
was absolutely incredible i was
tremendously impressed and i i do not
say that lightly i do not say it often
because i think
most podcasts are just a become an
elephant graveyard of
of you know two or three episodes and
the the effort put in
is very minimal but it was very clear
how well prepared sam was
how well-versed he was and how
emotionally connected he was
to paul when they were speaking it's
just a spectacular episode so i do
want to encourage people to check
that out and go to hellohumans.com and i
want to
then return to your july 4 to 6 blackout
and what you mentioned
and i'm paraphrasing probably was that
grace found you
and my follow-up question that is what
did that feel like
how would you describe that experience
well i can reference it by tying in the
paul williams
podcast actually when paul talks about
having won the academy award
for the barbra streisand movie where
he's standing before 100 million people
being given the greatest accolade that
the entertainment world can bestow on
someone
and he stood there in that light in the
light of that and he said it bought him
24 hours
24 hours of of elevated feelings
feeling good a feeling like he wasn't a
piece of [ __ ]
he was drinking and using and so
when i got clean and sober i had three
books published i mean i was doing
really well in the
world's eyes i live in the same county i
was born in i know everyone here
i am loved out of all sense of
proportion i had three books published
they'd done really well
and i knew secretly that i was
a fraud and dying i just felt like i was
my soul was so besmirched
what i did with other people what i'd
done to women friends
how i had dishonored my own self and
i got that it wasn't out there
in a great feature article in a local
paper let alone
on the academy awards stage that it was
an inside job
and that it was going to not be
available to me if i kept chasing down
the fame and the fortune and the attempt
to be perfect at what i do
and i learned pretty early on
like july 7th i got sober and i think
i realized by the end of that first
month i was very frail
and i weighed no pounds which i loved i
also had a massive eating disorder which
i missed because i was like 20 or 30
pounds less but anyway
i realized that this my life had been
like
greyhounds dogs at the races you know
out trying to outrun each other and but
that the dog who won
actually had caught up to a battery
you know with fake fur pasted to it
and that what that was what you win or
that it was like glenn gary glenn ross
and if you got second prize you got
the steak knives and i had that
spiritual awakening which was
as important as it gets that it's not
out there
that it doesn't have to do with what you
can buy
or achieve or lease or own
or date and that it was going to have to
do with some kind of
union with your own truth and with your
own
self and that had to do with through
that union
with a power greater than ourself and
the great universal energy
and uh the bigger reality you know
and the first week of being sober i have
to say
was not a high point in my life i was
extremely anxious and
kind of frantic and it was my best
friend and everybody loved me when i
drink i'm a really funny sweet person
and i sleep with everybody so to give
that up was kind of crazy and you know
i'd wake up
really sick and i'd think about having a
beer
just to get all the flies going in one
direction and people like me when i've
had a couple of beers and
and so i felt like who will like me now
who will like me
if i'm not chasing the bunny at the
greyhound track who will like me
if i'm visibly scared and uptight and
sad
and it turned out that these other women
did they said we're gonna love you till
you can learn to love yourself
and in fact sam when when he was uh
eight or nine
we were watching king kong the jessica
lang remake
and he always said this trippy stuff but
he watched it and he
he turned to me and he said she loves
him
because she can see that he's lonely
and i just wept when he said that that
jessica lange
loved king kong because she could see
that he was lonely and that's what
really what the people
who helped me get sober and also at my
church i went to this
i go to this funny little failing church
that's half black and half white can
hardly pay the electrical bills and
it was the same thing i went there drunk
and bulimic
and stoned and they loved me because
they could see that i was lonely
but i couldn't take it in until i
stopped self-medicating like you
referred to with over caffeination
once i was there and i was settled
with somebody who was really safe and
listening
then i could begin to have a more tender
gentle feeling towards my own
anxious and disappointing self so i
could see that the anxiety
was part of what was so beautiful about
me like for instance when i was coming
up
i was very very sensitive i think that's
why i got migraines but that was always
i was
so shamed by the culture by my teachers
and my parents
for being so sensitive there was a book
my parents read called
the overly sensitive child you know that
helped parents not have to have their
lives ruined because their child
saw the cover of national geographic and
that the children in india
had flies or were starving to death had
flies on their eyes
and it was all about trying to help me
not be the person that i was which was
very very sensitive
and i was gravely shamed for it when i
was
got sober my friend tom weston told me
these five rules of being human that
changed my life i'll tell you them now
that had to do with who i was and how
why i was so shamed for being who i was
born to be
the first rule is you must not have
anything different
or wrong with you you just must not have
anything
different about you or wrong second rule
is that if you do
you really have to get over it as
quickly as you can you really have to
fix that
it's really a problem the third rule is
that if you can't
get over it or fix it you should just
pretend that you have
that it's really not an issue anymore
the fourth rule
is that if you can't even pretend to
have corrected it you should just not
show up because it's just so painful for
the rest of us to have to see you
in your current condition and the fifth
rule
is that if you are going to insist on
the right to show up you should have the
decency to be ashamed
i was toxic with shame
from my earliest earliest years to
32 when i got sober and i covered it up
by being so successful and
so charming and just such a snappy piece
of cheese
and when i heard those words which are
somewhere around 86
i realized i was home free that that was
the work i was going to do
was that i was going to insist on the
right to show up as is
with my funny hair with my funny thighs
with my hypersensitivity with my
big open heart and i was not going to be
ashamed and if it was a problem for
you then you were gonna have to go i
wasn't gonna keep trying any harder
to get you to see that i'm just totally
fabulous and unique if it doesn't work
for you it doesn't work for you you know
you know this not everyone's going to
like you and like your work
lots of people can't stand my work
either
the political people because i'm a
christian or in the and the christian
people because i'm the left-wing
activist
you know people a lot of people you must
have gotten horrible
put downs and criticism in the media
sure and you have to
you know you go okay look thanks for
sharing and this is not a place where
i'm going to spend a lot more time
because
i don't know how long my life is going
to be but i don't have time for this
kind of crap
right totally so that was how
i think that was an equation let's say
that helped me know what my work on this
earth was going to be
was that i was going to stop trying to
fix and change and correct myself
so that the culture and society would
think i was
more of a success you mentioned the
backstory on bird by bird
you mentioned el doctoro and the writing
is like driving at night with the
headlights on
we talked a little bit not much about
shitty first drafts
and i'm actually going to ask you a
modified
question based on a question that sam
asked
paul which was something along the lines
of if you look back
at all the songs you've written is there
a line or lines that really encapsulate
your
life philosophy or philosophy something
like that and paul's answer was you give
a little love and it all comes back to
you meaning leaning into kind moments
and leaning in in that way having
immediate medicinal effects on yourself
and others
i'm just wondering if after
writing so many books if there are
certain lines or passages or quotes that
really stick out as either part of
your life philosophy that is critical
for you
or just part of your fabric of being
either are there any particular
lines concepts or passages that that hop
out for you
oh boy it might be hard for me to think
of anything
on the spot but i know a quote that i
see
frequently around twitter the
twittersphere
is that everything will work again if
you impl
unplug it for a few minutes including
you
so so please elaborate so that's that's
i was going to ask you a question about
that
how does that apply to you and your life
well it's so
awful to see yourself tweaked
and maybe failing which we all do it's
part of the human condition
you know like vonnegut said welcome to
the monkey house
but we see ourselves feeling crying
or tweaking or twitching you know we're
getting a tick in our eye
and everything in us tells us to correct
it it's rule three
no rule two you should correct it as
quickly as possible
and instead what i need to do then
is to just stop i mean that's why i tell
my writing students just
stop just stop what you you know stop
living unconsciously stop trying to
force everything into submission
and stop and what i mean is unplug
turn off your phone for five minutes you
can do it turn
everything off if you need to cry cry
we're so shamed into not crying
growing up because i had a mother from
england if we started to cry
at the dinner table we went to our room
without eating
and for me crying has been the way home
crying and rage have been the way home
my parents
never expressed rage not once and they
hated each other
they were like a harold pinter play with
this very clipped
area died conversation i've had to teach
every woman i've ever helped
help get sober let alone all my sunday
school kids
that to cry is going to bring them back
into the fullness of their own selves
it's going to bathe them it's going to
baptize them
it's going to hydrate them it's going to
water the ground at their feet where
god knows what funny seeds have been
dropped by birds and will grow
with just a little bit of water so to
unplug
for me sometimes means crying usually
for me to be
on that forward thrust or the rat
exercise wheel
is because i am trying to stay one step
ahead of the abyss
and i'm trying not to feel my feelings
i'm just trying to
it's mood altering for me to be so busy
and to be at such a high level of of a
you know conversation and achievement
and if i can just stop
and unplug i might start to cry i might
start to realize how
furious i am and how scared i am of
being furious
when i was coming up in the 50s an angry
woman was about to get
exiled believe me by about 61
an angry woman was replaced by a cute
young
woman who wasn't so angry you know about
61-62 because of hefner
the men started leaving and they left
the angry ones
and they left the weepy ones and they
left the ones who didn't keep their
weight down
so there were a lot of societal
constrictions on having
emotions and states of mind that were
not pleasant
for the men to be around and for me it's
this kind of frantic need
to do even more and to do it even better
and like you break down you know i think
all three of us you me and sam have had
periods that we would refer to as
breakdowns where we just
ground to a halt and uh ran out of any
more good ideas and didn't even care
you know we're just kind of done and
from those places for me and i know for
sam
uh and i assume for for you tim that
from that and maybe not later that day
or thursday right after lunch there was
new life
there was transformative renewal of some
sort
and so to unplug means that
you stop and your shoulders sag and you
sigh
and your head drops your shoulder and to
anyone else to anyone in the world
it would look like you're doing really
badly but what you are is like an
electrical car outside the health food
store plugging back in
and everything like everything literally
works again if you unplug it
that's the greatest truth i know now one
thing i'm famous for something i didn't
actually say which is sort of
embarrassing
but it's like mark twain on the internet
or yeah
tom weston again my jesuit friend said
years ago maybe 30
it was 30 years ago because sam was two
and we were with tom in mexico and he
said you can tell you've created god in
your own
image when he hates all the same people
you do
and i i said it in one book and
attributed it and then a couple times i
didn't attribute it i have to say
embarrassingly enough and uh but most
people attribute it to me and i've spent
about 10 years saying it's not me inside
me now i don't care anymore and tom
doesn't care
but that's a great line that i would
like to be known for
[Laughter]
you said something in passing a while
back that i want to come back to
and that was related to your anxiety
disorder and you said most of the time
it's
it's treated well what has been helpful
for your anxiety disorder or
anxiety overall for you medicine
i um have a severe biochemical imbalance
i had it as a child
i had ocd i had to turn light switches
on and off 17 times before i could get
into my bed
if there was any sound in the house
between the switching
light switches and the bed i had to go
back and do it over
there was a system my whole issue has
been safety and whether i was safe or
not and i
basically never was but i was also
addicted to unsafe people because
it was about maybe getting it to come
out right this time
when i was coming up there was no
awareness that children could have
really
terrible biochemical disorders where
they would have to spend a tremendous
amount of energy just getting to where a
regular
kid without an imbalance would start off
like you and sam have both talked about
having severe depression at times
in the past and that's not something
you're kind of going to think your way
out
of you weren't supposed to and it's not
something you're going to go to ask
for it's going to be something that is
going to be
holistic whole body spiritual
psychic physical and for me medical
and so i found a great therapist
so many years ago and he found a way to
help me
get more imbalanced so that i don't like
without
the medicine i'm on i mean i have plenty
of anxiety everything i write about
is how i'm how anxious i am and then
when
when you and i leave i'm going to be
really anxious and think well this
didn't go well
or my answers were too long or he
probably won't even run it
so i have plenty of anxiety but i don't
have constant thoughts that neil or sam
or jax will die
which i have without treatment as a
part of my holistic healing with from
this anxiety disorder
i mean i still have ocd i'm going to
have it but i don't do the light switch
anymore so that's progress
not perfection it's holistic i eat a
certain way
i have prayer and meditation as very
important parts of my life
you know with my writing book you will
remember this i really believe that
discipline is the path to freedom so
that with writing students i never just
say oh just wait for inspiration
wait till you feel like writing i don't
say that and with myself i don't say
wait do you feel like meditating
i don't think well wait till prayer
comes naturally i
pray help me or thank you you know help
me i'm so
crazy right now i'm so afraid or i
hate myself so much right now i'm so
afraid
i do my meditation as an act of freedom
and i tell the truth you know you and i
were laughing about how much we love
elizabeth lesser
and she had written a book about the
miracle of telling people the truth
and it ended up being a book about that
that's published
marrow it's called she's the head of
omega
that was about her sister's blood marrow
transplant that she was able to be the
donor for but i said it's such a great
topic you know blurting it out as a path
to
healing and every day i can say that i
either tell
neil sam or my best girlfriend something
kind of awful
[Laughter]
kind of unseemly that probably a person
who
is supposed to have this spiritual
wisdom or some spiritual tools at any
rate you'd be surprised that she still
goes there but i tell them
you know what they say they say oh thank
you for telling me that i was there
tuesday
and i told you and you and i ended up
laughing
and laughter is carbonated holiness and
then we got a bag of eminem so we drove
around town listening to the beatles and
eating m
ms and we both got so happy so that
realm of
telling it out saying it telling one
person
for me is how i let go
of whatever's vexing me you know people
always say
very sweetly let go and let god and i
just want to stab him in the head with a
plastic fork like they're a
baked potato because obviously if i
could like oh i would have
you know and you hear in recovery that
everything we let go of has claw marks
in it
but the way that i can
create stuff for you or to to a group of
people or whatever
and when i tell it i get my sense of
humor back
and i also i might get people that tear
up because i've trusted them with my
truth
and they nod and they say me too
and then we're i i get to hook into
something
so much bigger than my own troubled
judgmental mind
so i'm going to jump on the m m's we're
going to come back to the
the claw marks in truth and uh prayer
but we're going to begin with eminem's
so i in the process of doing homework
for this
i looked at a number of interviews and
in one
feel free to correct this but i read a
bit about your writing process
and here in front of me i have it it's
from inlander i think that's correctly
in it it said inlander.com i sit down
quite early give myself short
assignments
dot dot dot so i think it's truncated as
a quote and reward myself when i
finished a tough paragraph for passage
msnbc and some eminems no music or noise
and i wanted to start with the last part
do you
still follow that rule no music no noise
you're right in silence
yeah i do i'm i'm so easily distracted
and this is what my dad did you know and
he wrote in silence he got up he was at
the desk at 5 30
every morning in his little study going
tap tap tap
you know on his old typewriter in
silence and he
loved music and as soon as he got up he
put on cold train or
or mozart and loudly and got us all up
for breakfast
but i write in the silence yeah and
what are some of the other rules that
you have for yourself when do you
tend to as you've mentioned i think
you're a fan of discipline and systems
when it comes to these things
could you elaborate on you know what
early means for you
and could you give some examples of
short assignments
yeah early means for me nine there's a
lot of us living on this property
there's one
my grandson goes to school goes to camp
he comes over to my house for breakfast
there's a lot of animals there's a
husband
and so i kind of do everything that
might distract me i try to be
at the desk at nine there's a chapter i
don't know if you would remember it from
bird by bird
on one inch picture frames and i always
had my students get each other one inch
picture frames and i have one on my desk
i could show you if we were in my office
and not sam's
so you look through the one-inch picture
frame and
you see one scene you see one thing that
happened
you see the first time you got in the
ice water
of maine the ice water lake
in maine when you were six years old
where
the parents didn't dare to go in and you
and the kids wouldn't get out
and in fact were blue when you were
finally fished out and your teeth were
like those
wind-up dentures and you just write
that's all i'm gonna write well the
critical mind
that neil writes about is going to say
what's the point of that
what does that have to do with anything
where are you going to use that
right and you have to let the critical
guy
be the ethical consultant let him go
back to the library and read a book and
wait patiently and you
write this one scene that has to do
with this one small piece of lake with a
relative
and your mom and your dad and your
brothers and a bunch of blue cousins you
know
bright blue shivering teeth chattering
cousins
and how that was like one of your first
experiences of heaven
but the mind is constantly going to tell
you there's not really a very effective
or efficient reason for you to write
this
that's what my writing students are up
against constantly that's why i think i
could help you with your novel if you
really want to give it a try
because in the beginning what you'll do
is you'll look through the one inch
picture frame
and all you'll do is to start scribbling
down these scenes on a legal pad
of of moments and memories
and visions and experiences
camp when you were nine years old and
that one moment in college where your
life changed forever
in fact let me ask you tim was there a
moment in college when your life changed
forever
oh for sure i there were many but
the one that actually comes to mind is
pretty dark if you're okay with dark
oh dark dark are us
it was it'll require a little bit of of
preface
but i had taken a year away from school
to work at several jobs and also to buy
time to finish my senior thesis
and i had come to believe for a host of
reasons that i've
i've written about if people are
interested
they can find it if they just search my
name and suicide some practical thoughts
but i had really landed my place in a
very dark abyss of hopelessness
and had not just
not just thought about suicide but
actually by that point decided
i had planned it i'd put it on the
calendar and
was i would say a week 10 days away from
implementing the plan
it was pretty well thought through quite
creative and
i had requested a book from
firestone library at princeton where i
was
well not then but had just been an
undergrad
about euthanasia or suicide something
like that
but i'd forgotten to update my mailing
address with the registrar
and as a result thank god for this but
when they mailed out a physical postcard
so in today's digital age
i wouldn't be here when they mailed out
a physical postcard to say your book has
arrived
for pickup it went to my parents house
and my mom
got this index card this postcard
and called me to ask me about it with
this
quavering voice and that snapped me out
of this spell
that i'd put myself under and
that was the wake up call that snapped
me out of it
and certainly things changed at that
point
very quickly could have turned out
differently but that's
that's the one that comes to mind well
that's an amazing memory
and that's a memory that almost anyone
who read it would would have a
experience that where the details were
completely different but where they
they grocked it you know they got how
you felt
sam at hello humans wrote a piece about
a terrible terrible breakup years ago
maybe six years ago where he ended up at
the bridge you know
and he wasn't climbing over the side but
he was in the parking lot it's pretty
close for a mom
and when he wrote it hundreds of people
said
thank you you know i have felt like that
i have been there i don't live in san
francisco so i wasn't at the golden gate
but i was on you know i was wherever
they were so
if i were your writing partner i would
say
will you tell me that story on paper and
write it really badly
you know it's gonna be six pages and by
the time i edit it i'm gonna let you use
three of them but write it long and
badly
just write it just do it now you can do
it just in an hour
okay that's what i would do so that's
how i talk to myself
when i'm working that that's an incred
these memories are just
so deep in our souls like they're not
obviously for entertainment value their
souls their the stuff of
the soulscape and the cycles that we
pass through
and so beautiful so that's what i do
that's what the one inch picture frame
in the short assignments
how they work i do a new thing you'll
like this i decided an
hour at a time is too long and
45 i do these things now i call pods
and they're 45 minutes long and they're
based on the one inch picture frame but
so
if you write for 45 minutes you can get
30 minutes of work done that's just
what the logarithm is that for 15 of
those minutes are kind of twisting and
turning
trying to figure out a way out of having
to write it all
and how anybody in their right mind
would see that you shouldn't have to
write for 45 minutes
well nobody cares if you or i write
again you know
the weed better and so but then i use
the bribes and the threats and the m
m's and the msnbc at the end of every
pod
to get 45 minutes an
hour to get 45 minutes written that's
what it is that's the equation
so an hour-long pod gets you 45 minutes
2 hours gets you an hour and 15 minutes
this is just realistic it's it's not
efficient
it's not what your teacher has taught
you it's the spiritual creative artistic
life
it's loopy and it doubles back and it's
like a mobius strip and it's three steps
forward
and two back but you got to sit there
because
you got to keep your butt in the chair
and because no one in your family is
going to be glad to hear you're writing
a memoir
or an autobiographical novel anyway
another thing i know a quote
that uh back to a question about half
hour ago but this also has to do with
our writing and this
writing down your memories writing the
truth i said
you own everything that's happened to
you
if people wanted you to write more
warmly about them
they should have behaved better
[Laughter]
well in other words you also you can
write it all down
any abuse any neglect that caffeinated
neglect that was so common all of it
everything you saw and we can take it
out later
or you can make it be happening to
another family that's why fiction's so
great
but it all belongs to you you own it you
get to write it
and um and we'll figure it all out later
that's what i always tell my students
look we'll figure it all out later
because they don't want to hurt their
families i had a student
whose mother used to hold his hand
over the flame when he had disobeyed her
on the stove
but you didn't want to hurt her feeling
she was an elderly woman by then
and i said make it be the family across
the street that you are best friends
with have their mother be the one
you own it she should not have done that
to you and you own it you get to work
with it
you get to use it see the voice that
critical voice
every step of the way is going to be
explaining reasons why
it doesn't matter if you write it that
you're beating a dead horse
or that you're going to hurt people's
feelings or any number of reasons why to
keep you from
writing but if you have this thing
inside of you
if you're not writing then you're not
whole you have to ask yourself
how alive am i willing to be and if
you're willing to be really alive
then you got to write your truth you got
to tell your stories
you got to do this deep union with self
or you have to ask yourself why am i
even here what's the point
let me ask you a question about the blue
cousins
in maine and i'll make it personal so
i've
i've written two fiction short stories
which is not many but two in the last
few weeks
and the first was really easy for me to
complete which i was surprised by but it
was it was almost entirely based
on real events so the first 75 percent
was basically
taking the the true events and sort of
putting them in a different wardrobe
but it came out very easily and then i
had to
fuss with it and have a few cups of
coffee to figure out the rest but in
in the process of a few hours i was able
to write a two-page short story very
short
and then i decided well let me try
something that's really
more from the imaginary realm
and this this proved to be i think going
to the deep end of the pool
without my floaties on my arms maybe a
little too early
and uh and i got into this story that
i'm
that i've been working on and i'm five
six pages in and i'm just like where is
this
going i have no [ __ ] idea how to wrap
this up what's the point of it so all
these voices
my specific question is if i don't know
where it's going and i have no idea what
to do and therefore
i'm even more prone to putting off the
writing for
polishing my tennis shoes or fixing the
doorknob or whatever excuse i can come
up with
would you personally for you or your
students
just start writing anything at all to
get the hands moving even if it's not
related to
the story in other words if you're
halfway through
some larger project but you really don't
know what to do will you just write on
something that's completely unrelated
well i believe that the people and the
material know
who they are and what they do and that
they
need to trust that you're a reliable
narrator
and this brings me to a whole thing that
i could do an hour on
which is that if you grew up around
alcoholics or
the mentally ill the first thing you
agree to is to not to see what's going
on
right because it makes them so unhappy
if you notice so you agree
you for your whole life you just agree
not to see what's going on
and so you lose the ability to trust
yourself
as the narrator of your own story
and so the material and the characters
will give you themselves and their
actions as they trust you
to get it right and so for me
that's why i really believe in the quiet
and the silence and i can i taught my
fifth the five-year-olds in this writing
workshop
close your eyes there's this screen on
the back of your eyes
can you see the people what can you tell
me about them
so you can get very quiet and close your
eyes and go inward
and then you can ask the people you can
ask the characters
what were you thinking then what did you
feel your choices were
why were you not willing to just say
what was true and that you had the
answer they were looking for you had the
missing purse or you had whatever you
can ask them
tell me something about you and what do
you think in this circumstance would be
plaguing you
here's the thing with the story you
might want to ask yourself what's at
stake
like you're trying to get to know these
characters better you can write it 20
pages on
tim i'm promising you this you can write
a 20-page short story
you can take out eight pages and then
you can send me the twelve
and i'll edit it for you but the thing
is that something has to be at stake
so what is you ask yourself and your
characters
what do they love most in the world what
are they at risk of losing
if they're not at risk there's no story
there it could be a child it could be
their sobriety
it could be their life but what what do
they stand to lose
so ask them and you can look at them
maybe there's two or three main
characters and you ask them
what couldn't you lose and then you put
some pressure on that
where that could be at risk and then you
can see
how they in fact respond do they run
do they put their fingers in their ears
and go la la la la la
do they drink only you know and these
people inside of you know
and you can ask them but the main
question is
there has to be something at stake in
every story that any of us are gonna
you know you're the ancient tribal
storyteller and you've said
do you all have a minute i've got a
story to tell you and we sit around you
at the fire
on the stones and you tell us the story
now we all love stories about ourselves
right
that's what the tribal storyteller tells
and that's what people like about my
story is that because they're
they're the stuff in me that i know is
universal it holds up a mirror to them
and so you say if nothing happens in
your story if nothing happens to their
the favorite character what's the story
it's not a story
it's so if it's right yeah and then what
you as the writer do
is mess with them they couldn't survive
if they lost their
partner if the partner left them that's
the single most
driving force in their life they
couldn't function if they lost their
sobriety that's
what causes them to panic they couldn't
stand it if something happened to one of
their kids
lean on them and then you can keep just
closing your eyes and studying them
you know if you have two characters who
hate each other put them in an elevator
that breaks down
you know and see how they react figure
out what they can't stand to lose and
then you've got us on the ceo
please don't let that happen no don't
make that
what's gonna happen
what was it like having a documentary
made about you
that was so weird it was just so weird
i'm kind of not even comfortable talking
about it because
i don't like having pictures taken to me
let alone movies taken to me but for
about six months freda mock
who'd made the academy award-winning
documentary about maya lin
and the vietnam memorial wall in dc
she and her family and a crew
followed me from place to place and
filmed me in
interviews and performances i did on
stage and stuff and
talking a lot about being a single
mother because operating instructions
was relatively new and
the one part of it i love i love the
stuff of my kid
in it because it's such such beautifully
filmed
home video but the stuff of my mom is
just breaks my heart it's so lovely my
mom i've written a lot about her and she
was a handful she was
i had to be her mother from about four
years old and
she got alzheimer's and that did not
improve the situation
and frida did a bunch of footage at the
place that my mom lived which was
assisted living
independent and then assisted living and
my mom she's very
befuddled and overweight and kind of an
embarrassment if you were her kid you
know growing up
it's just so touching it breaks my heart
i love it
so much that that is on film
but mostly i don't know
you must hate seeing yourself on film i
mean i think anybody in their right mind
does
yeah i i have all sorts of insecurities
when it comes to
audio and video took me a while
just to be able to listen to recordings
of
interviews with my voice in them i
learned
recently why just as a side note why
we don't hear ourselves the way we think
we sound and it's because
when we speak when we're the origin of
our own
voice we're also getting the vibration
of the skull and the bones
of the jaw and so on in her ear the
different components of that
there's a resonance of that vibration
that combines with the sound that then
reflects
off of the walls and so on so it is in
fact a different voice the voice that we
hear and the voice that others hear
but quite apart from that i'm wondering
why you agreed to
to do the documentary i don't know i
have to say before i answer that that i
was on rosie o'donnell's show 20 years
ago
and sam was watching the replay when i
got home from filming
and he listened and then he said very
nicely
mom do you have a speech impediment
and i've never gotten over that and i
just believe i have a very severe speech
impediment
but
wait what was the question again the
question was
yeah yeah why do you agree to do the
documentary
i don't know i i think it was partly
that this i was a bit of a star [ __ ]
you know and that frieda
academy award and i could win the
academy award and
i would at least be up on stage when she
won the academy award and then
i was always broke too and i thought
that it would help me
start to make more money which it
actually did
but it was all that kind of stars in my
eyes thing that was the only reason and
then
she got really down and dirty and i
cried a couple times on
film when she asked about raising sam
without a father and
and what the men who helped raise him
meant to us how incredible
the bond was between me and sam and the
men who stepped in to father him
he didn't meet his dad till he was seven
that's what i live for
is for the depth to be revealed i'm so
sick of the surface stuff
and the performance art [ __ ] that we
parlay most of the time or what duncan
trestle calls
he says when you first meet me you meet
my bodyguard
and what i live for are the comments on
film
or in books when the depth of our being
is revealed
like when sam and paul williams do that
interview
on hello humans they both weep because
they go
into the truth of their hearts and souls
and their being and their
pain and their their realness they do
real
and there's nothing more beautiful or
touching you know the ancient greeks
called god or thought of god as the
really real
which is certainly not something that
modern day religion
is very interested in but boy is that
really real
you know when you're in the presence of
it and it is
a battery pack and it is
so revitalizing it's thrilling
it's thrilling to be with the really
real whether it brings tears to your
eyes or it makes you
stop for a minute and then throw back
your head and laugh
let's talk about prayer if you're open
to that because
it's not something that gets talked
about much
on this podcast and specifically i'm
looking at
a number of quotes from your new book
dusk night dawn these were sent to me by
our mutual friend
elizabeth lesser so she she had some
selects that she sent to me
and one of them is very simple it's just
one line
the greatest prayer comma quote help me
not be such an [ __ ] end quote so
i'm using this as a segue into how you
pray when you pray
what it means to you this word prayer
but perhaps we could start with this
example so help me not be such an
[ __ ]
speaking to you now and hearing of your
history
of people pleasing and accepting the
leftovers
it's hard for me to imagine you being an
[ __ ] i imagine
that you know you're you're a pleasant
drunk you
are catering or have catered to other
people's needs
so what does that prayer mean to you
it was really my dad's battle cry he was
an atheist both my parents were atheists
but he had this ethical moral core both
my parents said they were very big
in civil rights movements and and his
thing was just
don't be an [ __ ] be kind and
they had no spiritual interest at all in
fact they kind of had a list of
who were the craziest religious people
of all
in order and who which christians were
crazier than you actually had to be
but their path was about kindness and
about service to others
and they did feed the poor and they did
take clothes to the cold they took warm
clothes to people that were cold on the
street
and they did give away what they could
and
but when i'm an [ __ ] it's usually not
that flagrant because you know i have a
i have my appearance together i've got
the surface nicely burnished and
what i do you can ask sam or neil i get
very quiet
and then i weaponize that quietness and
it's very
scary people find it very scary i hear
but i just i stop caring and i get very
judgmental
and i'm very you know most of the time i
mean a lot of the time i'm just
in judgment because it's so much more
interesting than being in kind of
peaceful and moseying along and being
ferdinand the bull
it's so fun to be in judgment especially
with a friend
you know and to be doing gossip and
judgment and so
i think that that's fine and that we get
to be really human and
and whatnot i heard when i first got
sober
the willingness comes from the pain you
know and the healing comes from the
tools of recovery and of of our
spiritual lives
meditation prayer walks naps
but the willingness comes to the pain
has really stuck with me and when i have
made myself
toxic because i'm being i'm acting in
like i'm feeling like an [ __ ] i'm in
judgment
i'm s done with somebody i'm sick of
them
and i feel very cold and uncaring
towards them or i feel uncaring to whole
swaths of humanity where i feel
like tom said you know i create you can
tell you've created god in your own
image when you hate all the same people
he does when i'm in those states
i create a lot of pain for myself it
becomes kind of
metallic and like sheet metal inside of
me you get you know that cold
hard when your heart gets cold and
hard it's just so miserable and again
back to awareness you know as soon as
you have the awareness that you're there
then you can start to use the tools that
you have and for me it would be prayer
and telling somebody i'm really stuck
right now i'm in
hostilities and i'm in you know the
troubles like in ireland i'm in the
troubles i think i'm right
i'd rather be right than happy you know
the buddhists are always
gonna be quiet or happiness i could
rather be right okay
but or the great krishnamurti said when
he was asked where he
found spiritual peace and what his
message was he said
i don't mind what happens you know and i
mind about half of everything that
happens i mind that he
said that he doesn't mind what happens
and when i'm there
i need help and the help comes from
being the in the awareness
that i'm in a cold sheet metally place
in my heart and i either need
the breath of the holy spirit you know
or i need
my best friend to drive around with me
and we go get an
overpriced cup of chai somewhere and
maybe some
carrot cake while we're there and i need
help
and i deserve it and i can ask for it
you know people
love love love to be there for you and
it's
for me it's so easy to save and fix and
to be the help
because i was like a flight attendant in
my family as i've expressed
but um so hard for me to ask her you
know the great poet william blake said
we're here
to learn to endure the beams of love
and i just that's beautiful terrifying
and it's the most beautiful
burger and it's terrifying we're here to
learn to endure the beams of love i know
you go through this with your girlfriend
that it's scary to be loved
it's scary to be forgiven it's scary you
know what it's scary to be accepted as
you
are it's just like what's the catch
i'm sure your family was just fine but
in my family that never came up
you know that unconditional love and
acceptance of who i was at any given
time
it was usually about changing me to be
who they really hoped i'd turn out to
grow up to be
and so it's so trippy
that just that one line and to practice
burying it
you know to practice bearing it your
metaphor of the flight attendant brings
me to
this anecdote i'd read of yours when you
first hit the new york times list and
you called your mom and said oh my god
mom i hit the list
and she replied with oh huh anything
else
which sounds brutal and certainly can be
extrapolated to
influence so many things what you just
said about the sheet metal
this coldness
is actually a feeling and a response i'm
very very familiar with
and it reminds me i wish i knew the
attribution somebody can find it but i
have a quote
which really stuck with me which was
that hate is not the opposite
of love the opposite of love is
indifference
and i've thought about that a lot
because i suppose for many different
reasons and childhood experiences and so
on
from a very young age i became very
adept
at instinctively dissociating yeah
and it's it's really been
a project to work on that yeah because
it is
it is second nature when you pray do you
have
in case of emergency break class ad hoc
use of prayer
do you well in addition to sort of on
the as needed basis
do you have a routine of prayer at
different times of the day or a week or
anything like that
i wake up and i pray i say a prayer
everything i wake up and i
pray a prayer from recovery about just
help me keep my sticky fingers off the
controls of this spaceship you know help
me move
and you know i know i know as sure as
i'm sitting here
that if i want to have really loving
warm feelings i need to do really
loving warm things and i can do them for
myself
i can put lotion on the parts of my body
that i
don't love quite as much let's say and i
wish i'd
remembered to go to the gym after i had
a baby but i didn't uh 30 years 32 years
ago
i i can do loving things with me acts
take the action and the insight follows
you don't think yourself
into having a warm generous heart you
act your way you do loving things for
other people
and so i pray to have that awareness i
pray
to be paying attention to life you know
all around me to the
golden crown sparrows that migrate
through my part of the woods in the
fall into the daffodils that are only
here for two months with their crazy
orange and yellow
clown frills and two to the little bit
of green
shoots that somehow i don't know how to
break through the concrete
and to pay attention you know and as a
writer you know henry james said a
writer is
someone on whom nothing is lost so i pay
attention and i get material
i scribble it down and i gather like
rags for the rag bag guy in my soul
which is what you're doing with your
writing right
now you know you're amassing like these
squares to use for a quilt that you're
going to
crochet together and there's some of
them are unbleached linen and some are
silk or velour
or old piece of denim and you you don't
don't judge them you you amass
them so i pray to pay attention to life
as a kind of
troops all around me and i'll tell you
one thing
there was a guy who helped a.a get
started who was not himself an alcoholic
he was a priest
this is 1935 and he said to bill wilson
who was one of the craziest people in
america at that time
he said sometimes i think that heaven is
just a new pair of glasses
and i think about that almost every day
because i can either have the glasses on
that are like
x-ray glasses where i can just see
everything that's wrong
with almost everything really because
i'm good at that i've made a career of
it
or i can put on the glasses where i feel
a lot of compassion for everybody and i
see
how hard they're trying and i see that
they got dealt a really shitty hand of
cards
and that they played it the very best
they could and i see with these
the better pair of glasses that how much
beauty is all around me it blows me away
and it makes me free and it makes my
life much more expansive
but i need to remember and the way i
remember is to pray
to have the good pair of glasses on
i love that i would like to revisit
the incredibly named horrible bonnie
how did horrible bonnie come into your
life and
can you please paint a picture for us
who is horrible bonnie
what are any lessons learned or benefits
imparted from
from time with with horrible body and
why on earth is her name horrible bonnie
so many questions but please just
tell us the story of horrible bonnie
well her real name is bonnie allen
and she has been my spiritual mentor
since i got into recovery
and she has been with me every step of
the way through
early sobriety through having a baby
without a partner or a
scent in the world through sam's
mess and through a baby
sam's baby at 19 through breakups
through
custody battles through poverty and
every step of the way she just sees
so much blessing and she's
and it drives me crazy and no matter
what
shape i call her in which is to say in
completely enraged spoiled brat
narcissist mode she says oh
dearest i'm so glad you called and that
you trust me with this
that's why i call her horrible bonnie
because it just drives me crazy
never get on the bus with me where we
just trap like
she doesn't she wouldn't trash trump
with me and she loathed them
but what she'd see was that incredible
miracles
and blessings were gonna spring from the
four years
of having trump and that she would have
me put on the good pair of glasses and
see
what was springing from this you know
that was going to change the world
forever
what was going to change me forever what
she helped me do was to find my own
inner donald trump
who's bombastic and self-righteous and
victimized and it changed things for me
it really changed trump for me when i
found my own inner donald
trump and it's that sort of thing you
see what i mean that you could call her
in rage and judgment and she'd just
wreck it for you you call her in
superiority
he'll just wreck it for you but i wanted
to add one thing if you don't mind
when you were talking about the
disassociation because that's been very
very important for me
and the inner donald trump is a part of
that that horrible bonnie
helped me start welcoming these people
that i try
these parts of myself that i cannot
believe are part of me
that i can't stand that i recoil from
and she had me
start welcoming them to the table to
where we're gonna have soup tonight and
it would be like blanche dubois you know
that my inner blanche dubois would be
somebody who pre is a predator
and who preys on people because she has
zero self-esteem
zero sense of self and she she uses her
feminine wiles and her victim
to to lure people in and to do for her
what she can't do for herself and to
elevate her sense of self
and donald trump this person this me
who really is such an [ __ ] and to say
you know what
you're a part of me come we're going to
have soup we're going to have
potato leek soup tonight can have a bowl
with us
and to make friends with it and you know
this is terrible it's probably the worst
thing i've ever said on the air
but about four months ago knows more
than that but there was a fire in a
place
in a town where i hate somebody i hate
an
entire family oh god i can't even
believe i'm saying this
but i kind of thought good i thought
good and i caught myself and actually
laughed out loud and i thought oh my god
and then i realized it was my inner
maternal grandmother whose name was jane
she was my mother's grandmother and they
grew up on the docks of liverpool they
were poor
the husband was a dock worker he died
when my mom and her twin sister were six
and her mother who was named jane was
this cold
dimly-eyed person who just hated people
and who wanted bad things to happen to
people it was my inner jane
and you know what i said to jane we're
having
minestrone tonight come eat with us so i
had like
blanche dubois donald trump
jane and but i also have these incredi
like my hero
i found my inner amelia earhart and i
found it for married couples it was kind
of threatening that i've gone so
many places i've gone so far in my
career i've traveled the world i've done
things that might have been hard if you
were married
and that i was so brave to do that they
might not have felt brave enough to do
and so i found amelia earhart and i
would kind of tamp it down
so it didn't make other people feel bad
about their own accomplishments and i
thought
no i don't know how long i'm going to
live but i'm not going to pretend
that i don't have this pioneering
crazily brave woman inside of me and so
i would say to amelia earhart
we're having portuguese wedding soup
tonight come eat with us
and so you've got all these parts of me
that i have cut off that i welcome back
on my path to wholeness you know in the
new book a lot of it is about soul
and maybe all of these people are a part
of what i would dare to call souls that
my sunday school kids saw as a
the innermost russian nesting doll one
of my sunday school kids said he thought
it was a
silvery snow globe in the very center of
me
or like a kiosk from which the world
troops by and i say hi to people and
wave
and so maybe in the very center of me
there's not the person my parents wanted
me to be
or who i pretend to be or who everybody
thinks i
am but it's this kind of hodgepodge
thing that's too big for one
set of clothes and it's all the beauty
and
all the cork and all of the damage
and all of the everything and it was
exactly as it was meant to be
and it's like i can push back my sleeves
and live from there now
live from my heart live from the heart
cave
live from the table where all the people
have joined
me for dinner for soup
it sounds like whether it's with the
assistance of horrible bonnie or
on your own that many of these
reframes are the practice of
sort of manifesting heaven as you quoted
earlier of putting on a different pair
of glasses
and i'm really glad that you paused to
talk about the
the re-integrating of these parts
of yourself and i have
personally found i would say related
work
with someone named dick schwartz richard
schwartz the
founder of something called ifs internal
family systems which is
somewhat strangely named but is very
much along the same lines
to be incredibly helpful and
i was gifted this right here you can see
it because we're on video
which is actually a small rectangular
piece of metal
that is intended to be a bracelet that
you strap on your wrist
and it's a quote from neil donald walsh
i believe
is the correct attribution the struggle
ends when the gratitude begins
and i just i try to look at this as much
as possible because it is so
tempting to busy myself with
tunnel vision looking over the horizon
of things yet to come
real or imagined but at the end of the
day man
is this type of reframe and the reframes
you're talking about
such potent medicine i would like to ask
you about the title of your new book
how and why the title that you chose
you you are exceptional at titling books
i must
i must tell you and wordsmithing in that
way it's
very impressive so how did you end up
choosing
this particular title well my last book
the book before this was called almost
everything thoughts on hope so i've been
traveling around the world to
the country to bookstores and theaters
talking about hope and the people in my
audiences
just did not feel a lot of hope they
felt sad and scared
and they felt very worried about trump
and the u.n climate change papers had
come out that were just devastating
where
the climate scientists didn't really
feel we could turn this around and so
i really felt that as a as a driving
dream of mine to be able to tell real
stories
from my own life and others that would
help people realize
how hard things could be but how good we
are at hard
and so i i always love this novel by
gabriel garcia marquez
called love in the time of cholera did
you you probably read that in college
i thought it was just just as good as uh
oh my god my mind went playing never
mind
thousand thousand years of solitude or
100 years of solitude one of those
it takes a village but uh 100 years of
solitude
we got there and so i kind of had that
as it was soul
and hope in the time of trump and the
u.n climate change papers
and so i felt that we were very very
much had trends gone from the dusk
of climate disaster to the night
of a lot of craziness and brutality
and hopelessness but that the dawn
always
arrives and so i wanted to be as
fearless as i could be writing about all
three of those stages
but just helping people remember the
dawn always comes
you know and that and all i heard
something tim i thought was beautiful
which was that twilight refers to dusk
and on twilight is the when the light is
fading and becoming night
and twilight is when the night is fading
and becoming dawn
and so i wanted to write these stories
that were as real
as possible but that that we're as
hopeful
and real as i possibly could
before we go though i want to give you a
writing prayer
because i do have a prayer when i write
especially when i'm writing novels which
are hard
so i tell all my students i pray
help me get out of the way to write what
wants to be written
because i believe the material and the
characters as i said
know who and what they are what they
would do in certain circumstances
but this k-fucked radio is playing and
i'm trying to appear
where i want people to think i'm more
erudite than i am which i'm not i'm a
dropout
i want people to think i'm more literary
than i am
neil says that shapes of truth he has 34
tips for writers and one of them
is if you think it sounds really
literary it isn't
you know it's overwritten so help me get
out of the way to write what wants to be
written inside me
i'll use that tomorrow morning and
i was reading some coverage and
interviews related to dusk night dawn
at one point you quoted a
roomy poem or a line from it at least
which is through love all pain will turn
to medicine
and i just have to say that
i view you as a master
of using both love and laughter
as carbonated holiness to turn
your pain into medicine for yourself
i certainly hope and believe but also
for the people who
read your work and who are exposed to
you and i just want to thank you for
that
i i know it takes incredible
effort and focus it's not accidental
and i want to thank you for for doing
what you do
well thank you honey that's really sweet
and
if i could pull a complete 90 degree
turn just
one more question one or two more
questions from me
complete non-sequitur but
you seem to love movies you seem to
watch a lot of movies
and i would love to know if there are
any all-time favorites or movies that
you have
watched over and over and over again
that come to mind
anything that this question prompts
related to films
that you might recommend or or name for
people
i love movies more almost more than
anything
you know it's funny there's a scene in
the movie the mission
with robert de niro and jeremy irons
which most people didn't see
except for the they know the soundtrack
by neo
what's his name morris coney or
something
anyway it's called the mission and in it
jeremy irons runs a mission at the in
in the rain forest above below these
falls
where a tribe is being decimated and
robert de niro
is a soldier and he has killed a bunch
of people
and um he ends up at the mission and
he's got this
huge bag of weapons and everything that
has ever defined him
he and jeremy irons and another couple
of the brothers are climbing up past the
falls to where the
tribe is it needs so much help and
robert de niro in it's a scene it's
five minutes it's not it's nothing he
ends up talking to the
chief and the chief wants him to drop
the bag of weapons
and he's not going to they brought him
to this point he's exiled he's ashamed
he's suicidal
it's the darkest darkest place he could
ever be but he won't let go of the
weapons that brought him to this place
and it's non-verbal they don't speak the
same language and the chief kind of does
these expressions and these
faces and he finally takes a rope and he
cuts
this rope that holds the bag over robert
de niro's back
and robert de niro begins to sob and
they begin to laugh and cry together and
he
buries himself into the chief's neck
and it is one of the most profound
moments i've ever seen in my life
you know how we will not let go of the
stuff
the weaponry and the stuff that gave us
the illusion of power
the illusion of control and domination
we just won't let it go
it's so beautiful there's many movies i
mean i love
the godfather and i love i've completely
turned on woody allen so i i don't watch
him with any pleasure anymore but
up until about 25 years ago i had seen
all of his movies five and ten
times what are your favorite what's your
answer to that question
all right i'll buy i'll buy you some
time i want to i want to hear some more
from you
i'll mention a few there are the movies
that i'm embarrassed to admit
i'll give one that i'm not embarrassed
to admit and then i'll give a few that i
am
the first is an animated movie called
spirited away
by hayao miyazaki that's how you'd say
his name
in english it's it's a just a
mesmerizing
fantastical film and it's so deeply
layered
i lived in japan as an exchange student
for a year with
fam japanese families went to a japanese
school and
it just sparked so much
imagination and nostalgia and optimism
in me that's that continues to be one of
my favorite movies
of all time for each book that i've
written
i tend to have one or two movies that i
play in the background
on mute because i find writing to be
such a solitary experience so i'll have
a standing desk and then i'll have a
screen or projector of some type with a
movie playing in the background
but it has to be a movie that i'm very
very familiar with or it'll be really
distracting
so for the first book the movies were
shawn of the dead which is a comedy and
the born identity the firstborn identity
then
for let's see i think it was
i think it was for our body the two
movies were
casino royale the james bond film and
then
babe about farmer hoggett and the lin
the pig
and i came to really appreciate babe it
is it is a
nuanced hilarious movie
but if i had to choose one that people
might not
recognize that i think is really
beautifully shot
and packed full of
lessons although often they are
interlaced with brutality
there's a movie called the prophet i
don't speak french but it's french so
um something like that about
i want to say i'm going to get the
ethnicity
wrong but a young
man slash boy who's incarcerated
and is taught the ways of
sort of the prison power dynamic and
power dynamics by i want to say the
corsican mafia and it's about his
his ascent and his troubles
and his wins leading
up to the sort of grand finale of the
film
and it's beautifully shot it's very
brutal but
i feel like there's also a fair amount
of beauty in that film so those are a
few
that come to mind are there any others
that come to mind for you
you saw my octopus teacher right i did i
did favorite movies
you know there's a movie i've made sam
and my grandchild watch that
that changed my life it's called babazis
the persian movie from
do you see it from it's iranian if the
second name is a z
i z but it's like b a
b b apostrophe a b a z i z
and it's about uh you know it's the
great classic theme of a
uh it's a travel log with a very young
girl
and yeah it's bab apostrophe aziz
and the subtitle is the prince that
contemplated his soul
and it's a movie within a movie about a
very little girl taking her
extremely aged grandfather to a festival
of holy men
where you begin to understand he
probably is going to die
it's about all of life it's about life
and death and despair and renewal
and and crisis and death and
resurrection
and new life and people and
food and it's about an hour and a half
and it's hallucinatory and it changes
you on a molecular level
i am not making that up that's going to
be
on deck for this evening probably i'll
see if my family will begin to watch it
well annie this this has been such a
pleasure is there anything
that uh we haven't covered or anything
that you would like to say
or any requests you'd like to make of my
audience before we wrap up of course
people can find you at
anne lamotte on instagram twitter
facebook
it is anne lamott and we will link to
the books and the social websites
documentaries everything we've discussed
in the show notes at tim dot blog
podcast but is there anything you would
like to
add before we close up for this first
conversation
oh i'm not sure i would like to tell one
quick story if i might
please or people who both believe in a
higher power
and people who believe in goodness and
who believe that there is
some sort of loving energy in this world
that
bats last uh i would call it grace but
this woman in my recovery community
about 15 years ago had a very severe
oral cancer she'd had to have part of
her jaw removed in part of her tongue so
she had a really
dramatic speech impediment she did the
chemo and the radiation she was fine she
was in remission for
almost 10 years and then it came back so
she shared at group level that she was
going to have to do it all over again
maybe have a bit more jaw removed and
have chemo and radiation
everybody just was so panic stricken and
uncomfortable about it they started
doing what you do which is saying oh my
beautician's
son had that same thing and he's fine
now and oh this and oh that and oh
oxygen therapy and she just waved it
away like it was cigarette smoke and she
said you know what god's got it
and so i got that actually written on a
engraved on a gold coin
that i wear around my neck that i touch
constantly
to remember that i'm not in charge of
much except for maybe helping
the animals get the cans of cat food and
dog food open every night because they
have no
possible thumbs but i just know that
whatever you think of god you know good
orderly direction or group of drunks or
grace over drama or whatever
that life tends and tilts towards the
good and that we're cared for
all evidence to the contrary every step
of the way
we really are we're surrounded emily
dickinson
said that hope causes the good to make
itself apparent
and we're surrounded by that good and
we're safe that's why i tell my sunday
school kids
you are loved and you are safe so that's
what i'd like to leave
everyone with well that is the perfect
place
to bring this to a close and once again
annie
i feel very privileged and
happy that after all of these years
after you helped me from afar in my time
of need
that we're able to have this
conversation and i
had a an absolutely wonderful time and
took a ton of notes and will be watching
and looking up many things so thank you
again for taking the time
thank you so much tim i loved it
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's four
hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
element spelled lmnt what on earth is
element it is a delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw copic coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two
per day element is formulated to help
anyone with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance
exercise mountain biking etc another
application if you've ever struggled to
feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone
called aldosterone blah blah blah when
insulin is low but suffice to say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick-ass
no sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolff robb rob wolf who is a former
research biochemist and
two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief
marine units fbi sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it
element will give you your money back no
questions ask they have extremely low
return rates element came up with a very
special offer for you my dear listeners
for a limited time you can claim a
free element sample pack you only cover
the cost of shipping
for u.s customers this means you can
receive an eight-count sample pack
for just five dollars simply go to drink
elements.com
tim that's drink lmnt.com tim
to claim your free 8 count sample pack
one more time that's drink lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer
drinkelements.com
check it out this episode is brought to
you by
eight sleep my god am i in love with
eight sleep
good sleep is the ultimate game changer
more than 30 percent of americans
struggle with sleep
and i'm a member of that sad group
temperature is one of the main causes
of poor sleep and heat has always been
my nemesis i've suffered for decades
tossing and turning
throwing blankets off putting them back
on and repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever wide
because i'm using a simple device called
the pod pro
cover by eight sleep it's the easiest
and fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature
it pairs dynamic cooling and heating
with biometric tracking to offer the
most advanced
but most user-friendly solution on the
market
i polled all of you guys on social media
about
the best tools for sleep enhancing sleep
and eight sleep was by far and away the
crowd favorite i mean people were just
raving fans of this
so i used it and here we are add the pod
pro cover to your current mattress and
start sleeping
as cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as
hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
it also splits your bed in half so your
partner can choose a totally different
temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing
now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32
faster reduce sleep interruptions by up
to 40
and get more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways
it's the total solution for enhanced
recovery so you can take on the next day
feeling refreshed and now my dear
listeners that's you guys
you can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot
simply go to eight sleep dot com slash
tim or use code
tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-m eightsleep.com
for two hundred dollars off your pod pro
[Applause]
cover